WWE Superstar page and fighting with my
family which is available on blu-ray DVD
and on May 14th on digital as well and
look who's here in studio but the WWE
Superstar page good to see you no big
deal we just have Lena Headey in in the
costume you right I'm fine with my
father it's not a big deal I know that's
pretty cool huh yeah it's really free
once you'd like to watch this this movie
about your fear about you about your
face this is really surreal it's just
it's funny seeing my family watch it
tear like I didn't get to sit and watch
it with them but like just the reactions
it's just priceless they deserve the the
world so really happy for them
so again your your story is you're
living in the UK and you just fell in
love with wrestling is that what
happened my whole family wrestle right
so I got I grew up in the rest in
business I kind of fought it in the
beginning I was like now I'm gonna be a
vet this is what I'm gonna do but then
at 13 my dad was like well I'm short on
a girl so you're gonna have to get in
there no it's like sure why not I had no
experience and then I just fell in love
with it
you had no experience no experience
they're like the first scene that you
see in the movie is me as a child
taking my first bump in the ring with my
brother as the pink power in gently true
yeah and then you beat your mom at one
point sure did okay and that was a
pretty big moment for you was it
yeah it's wonderful but then I mean it
would become like a regular thing like
every week so it's kind of odd within
the end sorry ma and so how did you
eventually get involved with the big WWE
here
well they do to tour Zia in in Europe
Ren and I had to tryouts which they
didn't show the other trial and dubby
dubby but yeah they came over and they
hold him and then I was the only girl
like in the movie that tried out and was
the only one that got signed tear and at
first I try to be like in the movie like
okay I'm gonna dye my hair blonde and
get a tan and stuff like that but he was
just like no you look terrible
right so like I just I kept being myself
which is pale chick with a butt chin you
know okay dude well yeah you are who you
are and so you've just went with it yeah
and then when when did you first realize
like oh my gosh this could really be
just a immensely successful dream come
true stuff for you even to that this
point is still
like I still don't believe it you know
and just the success that we've had so
far is just like immeasurable it's like
incredible that wasn't like a 7-point
we're like okay we've made it right so
is this it's just a crazy journey well
there's a scene in the film that we just
showed a clip for we showed it a couple
of times it's really hilarious I'm
Dwayne Johnson playing J he's my friend
now okay DJ that's yeah that's what you
call him DJ :
yeah what was it like being around him
oh is crazy well I've known him for a
while he was the one who actually told
me about the movie like in the movie
when he pulled me aside I was it's real
but he also told me who's making a movie
about me at the same time which other
say they couldn't show in the movie so I
get a text on my phone it was like hey
it's DJ I would love to see you at some
point at WrestleMania you know and I was
like who the hell is DJ and why is he
texting my phone you know I was like
creeped out thank you and and then dean
malenko sit beside me he's just like
that's Dwayne Johnson you idiot you know
custom over and yeah and then I got
taken into drains office and he was just
like I watched your documentary I loved
it the documentary could fight with my
family watch you can see on YouTube and
he stumbled across it while he was
filming fast and furious and couldn't
sleep one night thank God for insomnia
and he fell in love with my family and
he was just like we're gonna make a
movie about your life and I'm like great
that's great that's how you found out
and that's how I found out and then he's
like oh and by the way you could a debut
tomorrow you're gonna win the Divas
Championship and I'm like well I'm just
crying my eyes out snot bubbles
everywhere you know eyelashes on my
forehead it was crying and he was just
had to meet issues like within five
minutes he just changed my life and then
he was like alright but don't tell
anyone so I was like okay so I woke out
the room and I bump into this other
female superstar it's just like [ __ ]
you good nothing like I'm just a really
big fan of duay and like I don't know
and it just kind of like walked away
into the shadows a little bit right yeah
that was how it happened so he told you
okay let's walk through this again yes
so the scene that we're talking about in
in the movie right is you are just
starting up your wet-behind-the-ears
right and you asked for advice
and he just gives you
a whole soliloquy yes is that what
happened did that really happen that
didn't happen okay so what cinema gets
an incredible scene right it's like 95
percent of the story is true for this
story it's just you know Dwayne saw
opportunity where he can be inserted
into the movie which is fantastic
because we could always use Wayne
Johnson a movie right especially if he
was right and he apparently because I
wasn't on this on the set for that the
for that point but apparently he looked
she did it in like one take he was like
alright that's dude this scene and he
just whipped out and then did the scene
in one go and then I mean Arnie he can
do it was so funny insane and so funny
so then again so he calls you up yeah
and he's the one who informs you person
mm-hmm he tells me in person yeah so it
was like the scene in the movie at the
end of the movie when he brings me into
his office at WrestleMania and then the
day after is when I debut to win the
Divas Championship
that actually happened he brought me
into it into his office and told me
everything
and you know calling my dad too which
wasn't yeah it was pretty much like that
where you put the phone down on him
because my dad's a very big skeptic but
yeah that seems true yeah that's just
amazing how crazy deputy superstar page
here on the Rich Eisen show did you have
a say in and who was playing you though
I mean no so I I helped out with
obviously the story part like Steven and
Wayne I would contact them like nearly
every day or they'd reach out to me
nearly every other day just asking like
they were very hands-on with how they
wanted this story they were like they
really wanted to be as real as possible
right but when it comes to the costs and
stuff I I was like I don't want to be
too InFocus obviously like it's that
movie and I don't want to be like well I
don't want to have playing me you know
I'm just happy you can have anyone play
me if you want it sure right maybe
Victoria Beckham like your say well you
know what I mean
so should we ask her a Twitter poll
question that we have right here sure
that go ahead Chris this isn't showing
it's the Rock's birthday 47 David
Beckham's birthday 44 yeah whose career
would you rather have Dwayne's that's it
that's nice yeah that's a no-brainer
there's a no-brainer Dwayne you didn't
stutter brainer yeah no I mean I'm not a
big fan so sorry David
David's out I know you're from the
country yeah exactly
Cody I'm a DJ it's DJ didn't Stephen
Merchant say that he started calling
them DJ what points do you think we
could do that right Wayne called him
Dwayne that's right
yeah that Dwayne Dwayne we feel very
cool that we can call him DJ that's all
very cool I'm cool man this is this is
really cool so you worked as a bouncer
also correct I sure did like 15 uh-huh
yeah and I I was very surprised about
you know I also got mum strength and was
able to like tackle down guys and stuff
like that and my parents pub yeah I used
to do that I remember having one girl in
like a headlock and sitting on top of
the never Wong is that fighting and I'm
like I don't know how I'm doing this
right yeah 15 years old and it's amazing
you had three women and the main event
at WrestleMania this year you do you
feel like you should take a little bit
of credit for that because of your 600
credit no I'm just kidding no I feel
like every every single female has
worked really hard when it comes to WWE
and the only thing that I did was just
set maybe a tiny bit of a different
standard when it comes to you know just
a different flavor of ice cream every
girl was beautiful blonde supermodels
and then you have like this I call
myself a little [ __ ] like walks in you
know we barely brush my hair belly you
know anything and it was just different
I just stood out a little bit yeah I
mean we're showing some some footage
right now what do you think of when you
watch yourself do this stuff right now
mister I actually can't do the rest
inside of things anymore so I know how
are you feeling good yeah my neck is
attached so I'm happy
and WW have been so wonderful I mean oh
laughs it's just the way that you said
so Cavalier like yeah my necks attached
yeah I'm healthy and happy I so I can
wish poses great right what was your
first meeting with Vince McMahon like oh
my gosh he's so scary even now what but
in in in a he's my boss kind of way like
he's so wonderful and he's like a big
kid really and he'll he's really he's
really playful it's just a really nice
guy but he's so scary and intimidating
because you're just like Hurley crap
this is Vince McMahon you know right and
now today he's just like what to you do
you think
what's your busy what type of figure is
he to you oh he's still my boss he's
still intimidates me okay yeah you know
the best memory I have of Vince give me
a good story is WWE Superstar page here
on the Rich Eisen show we were filming
tough enough for like 10 weeks and we
had to go on his private jet like all of
us like there was you had token you had
to yeah we had to cuz we'll go from raw
and we were missing Smackdown to go film
not tough enough in Orlando so who's
Anna yeah so there's like even Big Show
was on the on the jet at one point but
and then the crew that all the camera
crew and stuff so we all had to be on
there so I remember we were from LA to
Orlando and it was my birthday and
everyone was really quiet for out the
whole thing I was like everyone's really
tired you know I didn't mention the fact
that was my birthday but we land and
then usually Vince has like this certain
word that he says for everyone to be
ready to get off the jet right yeah so
we're like old like waiting around and
I'm just like why is everyone so quiet
and then he told his flight attendant to
bring me a cake and he got everyone on
the jet to sing me happy birthday and
I'm like oh my gosh Vince McMahon and
everyone on this jet ride I was singing
me happy birthday and I was like 22 or
something like that you know it was like
very surreal moment as well yeah I mean
wow it's amazing like do you still even
just pinch yourself but yeah this has
actually happened to you yeah then you
have a movie
yeah Vince every week that's cool you
may not want me to but you know get over
here it is just like all right you know
that's cool yeah
this is really cool I really appreciate
you coming on we've talked about this
film so over and over and over so it's
actually great to meet you in person
here now you live out here your West
Coast or now okay I'm so LA now
okay I love a good Straub ease all the
things breakfast burrito I don't know
okay Lakers game you know I mean a
Clippers Lakers game a nice run in Kenya
if you have you done a hike yet
Oh many years ago though I haven't done
it since I moved out here okay you're
years removed from a hike runch have you
launched yoga yeah I wouldn't try it
because I'm not flexible at so ever okay
in-n-out burger of course of course of
course yeah okay what else can we figure
out what so for Lausanne 12h isin show
is its staple of Los Angeles ocean
surfing swimming if you if you beached
it all no I can't swim you guys I need
help so no wonder you mentioned Los
Angeles life of Starbucks uh-huh
there's only a Starbucks in LA so
totally yeah that's why I heard we can
help you it's just the names jockeys all
right stop making fun of me over there I
will come over there put you in arrest
of me would you I I mean Josh the PR guy
is like absolutely not no that's that's
a no okay I wish I mean I'll do it can
you go outside I think I left my bag in
there nice yeah just stuttering what
could you do like what's the move that
you could actually oh no you know what I
can kick a guy in the nuts without
actually kicking him in the nuts yeah
I'm gonna pass on that hold on a minute
no it's my party trick I guarantee I
won't hurt you so is this could this be
sanctioned
can she trot it yeah okay let's see who
would who would volunteer for this work
come on spread your legs
Mike del to fall break let's take a
break Mike is about to join the ranks of
the unsullied here so again you can
perform a maneuver yes to kick him in
the nuts not make contact it's not gonna
hurt your nuts Wow Wow or anything in
between
that's a tea
fantastic yeah that isn't he fighting
with my family again I'm I've got the
DVD right here the director's cut
Stephen merchants been on Lena Headey
and now you WWE superstar Paige this is
about your life and your family fighting
with my family available on digital on
May 14 on on-demand on May 14th and it's
been out for quite some time bring it
home bring it home is essentially what
we're saying right here on the Richards
show when we come back television only
segments for the ages I think this has
got this has got this has got a Mireille
written all over it'll be very awful
it's on digital now it's available on
digital right now fighting with my
family is a great movie everybody should
go check it out okay we're back with
more in a moment we're back here live
you volunteered that yeah and you what
are we about to attempt to do right here
kick them in the nuts without actually
hurting him yeah do you will make
contact you I'll make contact yeah
that's okay but you will not hurt him no
well it doesn't matter you have no
desire to have children anyway yeah
exactly WWE Superstar Paige do we have
do we have go ahead and hit it there
Jenny if I was you I'd pull your shorts
up a little bit just so I can have a
bull's-eye all right Paige how about a
superstar Paige
[Applause]
you're the one who is make it fun are
you serious are you serious
[Applause]
[Laughter]
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app